[Music]  injuries at the workplace happen all the  time what are the top three things to do  if it happens to you we covered that in  today's legal minute with eric palacios  and associates the sponsors of this  segment  welcome to the legal minute i'm attorney  eric palacios today we're going to tell  you three things you need to do if you  suffer a work injury  number one be sure to report it to a  supervisor immediately it's best to have  confirmation and this can be done with a  text or an email  number two seek medical attention as  soon as possible although you have 90  days to see a doctor the longer you wait  the worse it is for your claim  number three tell the doctor or the  medical staff that you were injured at  work this way the doctors will fill out  the correct forms to protect your claim  this has been the legal minute don't  forget to  [Music]  palacios and download a call at  702-444-7777